"Watched SO many old PewDiePie vids".
"I loved him ... back in the days".
"Lowkey miss the old PewDiePie, when he used to be more often with Cry(Cryaotic) and CinnamonToastKen".
" To be honest, the old PewDiePie ... is better than the current him".
"I miss the old PewDiePie".
"I miss the OLD PewDiePie".
"OLD PEWDIEPIE".
(Fades to - NOPE, JUST KIDDING)
"I MISS the OLD PEWDIEPIE!!!!!"
Game in-voice: "Ah! Ah, ahh, AAAAAHHAAHAAH
(Still reading) "I spend all day watching OLD PEWDIEPIE - It was BRILLIANT!"
"I SCREAMED!"
"I MISS OLD ...
(voice dies out) poohdehpye! GOD!"
*MOURNFUL MUSIC*
(GMM)
Let's talk about that!™
*Good Mythical Morning intro music*
Now, listen ...
I've been doing YouTube for 5 - 5 to 6 years.
Aaand, uhhh
Obviously I've undergone a massive change from my 1st video, to my last.
I am very happy with where I am right now, but it still seems that many people ...
are stuck in the old days ...
and I get that!
That's where probably when a lot of people found my videos...
aaand ...
the first time you experience something is always gonna be the best.
AM I RIGHT??
Eh??
But I thought we gonna react to some old videos and react to some new videos and then we can ...
kind of ...
face the facts, and sea - see what it's like
Maybe I'm just crazy.
Let's start with "HAPPY WHEELS".
I get a LOT of comments about "HAPPY WHEELS" being like, good old days.
I did at least 65 HAPPY WHEELS episodes -
on the span of ... 11 months.
I would LITERALLY (Pewds said "'LILERY") record ...
10 minutes, uncut. No facecam.
I haven't even selected a level yet.
(In-game voice) "Pewwwdiepie!"
"Welcome back to HAPPY WHEELS"
"It's a pleasure to play ... "
I'm doing the OUTRO (INTRO, stupid) as I'm trying to find a level
*snickers under breath*
"But dad, I'm scared - NO, DAD! DA-ah"
Pewds (voiceover) Ha hoah!
"That did NOT go as planned."
"Dad, are you okay - AAAAAAHH! DAAAAAADEEE!"
Pewds(voiceover): Huh, hoe!
(Current Pewds): I get it.
(chuckles)
That was actually funny.
Pewds (voiceover): ... recording. Yes.
Look how I'm checking that I'm recording before I'm even starting.
I dunno... I get why people enjoy it...
and I = I still...  you can still see me in there
but..... it's so bad *laughs*
(voiceover) This poster, it shows how gay you are! Look!
Exposing myself here.
I don't know - I don't .. really don't like that...
I feel like that was...
I still make kinda stupid jokes that I shouldn't have made, ...
but I
feel like back then I didn't understand
I was so immature, and I just thought
things were funny just because they were offensive.
So I would say a lot of stupid
shit. I'm not proud of it - I really not.
But I'm also glad that I've grown pass it.
(Voiceover)
"But Dad, he wants to kill..."
"I'm not your Dad"
Like... this is 23 parts later and I'm still making the same joke about the boy.
It's just the same stuff, over and over.
Also, these videos, I literally just recorded myself, like, 15 minutes.
I probably record now for even five times
more than that just so I can get
entertaining material and just show the best stuff
Moving on to "Amnesia" -  the show that everyone associates ... the good old Pewdiepie with.
I love this intro.
I get nostalgic just seeing this intro as well
This is before - eh - "Binding of
Isaac" was popular as well, so no one knew where I stole that graphic art from (chuckles)
(voiceover) "How's it going bros, my name is Peewdiepie"
I look like such a little shit. (giggles)
(voiceover) "Behind this... I mean I put that in the pi... I put it... Oh god dammed.  I don't remember. I'm a fukin' wrong person ...
(voiceover) "Alright! Is this really my house???"
It's funny, cuz I get a lot of comments of people saying
"Back in the day, he was
so much more natural and didn't force that humor"
But literally, I was trying so fukin' hard
to make jokes while playing this game.
Like, there's literally a part that I accidentally kept in,
I - I get frustrated because I didn't
think the video as entertaining, so i say
"God dammit I'm not funny enough!"
(voiceover) "Yeh, yeh... yeh... yeh. Fuk, I don't feel like I'm funny today..."
We also have this. This is a video I
uploaded by mistake
It's got 300,000 views.
Back in the day, I
literally did everything last minute...
like I would make the video, finish the video, upload the video
and it was such a stressful process to do that.
But here, I wasn't home when I
published this video
Because me and my... I remember me and Marzia went to the cinema and I accidentally uploaded my
facecam, instead of the actual video, and published it.
So it's literally... 11 minutes of me just doing facecam.
I wonder what would happen if I
did that today (chuckles)
LOOK AT ME! LOOK AT THAT MUSTACHE!!!
*laughs*
Ohhh..
I guess so... *laughs*
*laughs*
I guess some habits never change!
Goddamn... I love how this is still up...
Now, "Amnesia", was my baby.
"Amnesia" was the - the series that really elevated my channel...
Here's one episode, from the play-through...
(voiceover) "That's good."
"I wanted to go back"
... of me trying to solve a puzzle
(voiceover) "I could jam you all day"
"That's what she said"
"That's what she said" joke. That's
hilarious (-_-)
I'm literally stuck on this one puzzle...
for the entire... episode.
Here is me using
"r*tarded" in the title, again.
I was very childish back then. I really should go
through and, like, censor lot of these videos.
(comment) "This was kind of frustrating to
watch. He kept going back and forth in...
... the sewer area instead of going back"
Uhh, yeah, I know. That's literally it... *chuckles*
My play-throughs were actually horrible. *laughs*
Man, I was so cute back then. I get it now.
I get it. I did look cuter back then
And to be fair, I was more scared back then.
First time I ever experienced horror games, it's obviously the worst time, you know.
I still get scared, and that's why mainly I don't play horror games anymore, ...
because, people expect like an epic reaction of me every time, ...
and unless there's actual jumpscares in the game, I don't really get that scared
And I still get terrified while playing video games
"Sophie's curse was the last video I uploaded, it did amazing and everyone loved it
And so did I. It still is very fun for me to get
scared of games, just not every single day
Also back... it was also interesting because back then it was so hard to find games to play
You can tell how Youtube has shaped
gaming industry.
This is a game called The Lost Souls. It was one of maybe--I could probably count the amount of
horror games before Slenderman on my fingers. Like, there were so few games
to play that made it for YouTube videos and
this was--this was one that was really good.
Now there's probably hundreds or
thousands of games like this
Developers have benefited from my
channel but I think I benefited as well
you know, it's a mutual thing...I used to like all of my videos. *laughter*
and good old Fridays
with PewDiePie recorded on a web cam
not that the quality matters. I've been criticized a lot
for having bad quality but I always thought people don't
care about the quality, they just want good and
entertaining videos. That always comes first.
But to be fair this is 13 minutes of me, uncut, just answering questions. Adjusting my webcam.
I was probably better at being more engaging
with audience, but to be fair my audience
was a lot smaller back then. I feel like
it's been a struggle for me to adjust to
from being so small to so big and still have
a close relationship with the audience
because that's why I love about YouTube, that's why I always read the comments and
always interact with you bros, is because that's
something I love doing. If you bros didn't
exist I wouldn't be making videos. Honestly, I
really, really feel like I've gotten that
connection back. We're doing these fine
creation videos together, where I react to you bros' creations and I love that
and listening to voicemails, reviewing
fanart...all that kind of stuff is so cool
I love that interaction between us. I feel like
for the first time in a long time that
connection is back and that's really
really important to me and instead of, like,
milking one game into one video I do
three games in one video because I
want it to be the best video it can be, I want it to
be as entertaining as possible
When, really, I could probably just keep these
three separate videos and
get that money. But honestly, believe it
or not, I care more about that the video
is entertaining. That always, always comes
first and these type of videos
like Keep Talking and No One Explodes--they got so much editing, so much work into them just to make it
as funny as possible, as entertaining as
possible
hours upon hours of work to get that done. I
think people forget that. And these videos
are hilarious, thanks to it. I'm sure if
they were uncut a lot of people would
love it the same way and enjoy it the same
way but not as many people would be able
to watch that long of a video. That's just the case. To me, the improvement is clear.
To me, I've grown so much as an entertainer,
as a comedian, but also as a person. I
feel like back then I was very childish and
very confused. I didn't know what I was doing but
I know I enjoyed it and it really is
thanks to you bros. I always read the comments, I
always listen to feedback and criticism
and I feel like that's an important part
criticism has really helped me grow
and I'm very happy about that. And more
than anything I am very proud of who I
am today and I am also excited to keep
improving for the future
Old, new--I feel like it doesn't matter.
I'm going to keep making videos that I
love to make and that hopefully you bros
love to watch and--really, thank you bros, so
much for watching me and supporting me
throughout the years, even though maybe
things are different,
even though maybe some changes you don't
love. And if you still support me
throughout that, I really, really
appreciate it. I had to make a decision
throughout the years where I said, I want
to make the videos I wanna make. Not only
the ones my fans want to watch because
then I'm not going to be true to myself
and what I do and eventually I'm just
gonna hate myself and what I do.
But, yeah. That's it. Old versus new.
Either way, thank you. And
if there's one thing that will never
change, it's the brofist. Thank you bros for
supporting me throughout the years.
Do you actually brofist on the outro?
Do you wanna do that just for good old times sake?
Alright, here we go. You ready?
Brofist.